hey guys before we get into today's
episode we have a really exciting
announcement so finally this has been
the worst for so long now yes but we are
finally dropping merch on september 13th
we got these two shirts which i'm so
excited about it's our favorite phrase
with bingham this is like one that goes
way back you've been a long time
listener tiff
uh didn't come up with it but like
she introduced it my yoga instructor
told me this phrase and the full phrase
it's uh just like the sun you two will
rise out of darkness and just like the
moon no matter what phase you're in
you're always whole so we created these
shirts that says no matter what phase
you're always whole and it has like the
moon phases yeah it super resonated with
all of us and plus we love the moon it's
freaking cool who doesn't love the moon
you haters
we also uh the company that we teamed up
with does really really high quality
t-shirts and so close those are so
comfortable
so we also have these sweatshirts coming
out in black and also lavender which is
a really cool color on um
a couple pictures of us i don't have
that in person because jess has it right
now but it says big mood on it super
simple because we wanted to keep it
simple and just kind of on the quality
of the hoodie um this is one of those
hoodies that
this company works with a lot of
recording studios so they work with
music artists and just like produce the
highest quality garments and they have
like metal things on the ties i don't
know these are all technical terms
metal thingies um but just they're hot
is high quality it's very high quality
what's cool about these is the more you
wash them the softer they get rather
than the reverse of normally you buy a
hoodie and it keeps getting deteriorated
these get softer and softer every wash
so yeah super worth it and if you want
to check it out we have a bunch of uh
pictures of everything you can check it
all out they're very limited stock
though so if you want one be sure to get
one on september 13th never come back go
to exactly go to bigmoodstore.com
bigmoodstore.com yay that's b i g m
m.com
thank you
and tell them we sent you
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to big mood hi
we have a special guest here with us mr
stephen green hi thank you yes some call
me the iceman
no they don't
plenty people do no
people in real life actually call me the
iceman
which is pretty funny thanks for coming
to our studio today
parking was a nightmare by the way
by the way if you're not on the inside
we're trying to we're trying to do some
redecorating this place [ __ ] sucks i
have to keep on moving my own car
parking is hell here what cars dude
yeah i moved my wife's car the whole
time yeah so annoying do you want to
tell the audience why you sold your car
i sold my car for crypto actually yeah
yeah it's funny because i was desperate
yeah because you're poor right you're
broke i'm broke and i'm i'm super broke
i'm a desperate man at the end of his
rope
so yeah i had to sell my car
unfortunately okay to make rent oops
he's selling his car
[Laughter]
to make mortgage
uh all right who else we got here gina
hi
that's gina totally just woke up from a
nap in nicki's and steve's room it was
great it was a wonderful nap
did you notice how i woke you up by the
way she's saying to me in spanish yes
which is what we sing to to you on the
morning of your birthday oh oh yeah that
was the happiest i've ever woken up that
was really nice you're welcome yeah i
really like that that's cute you're in
mom mode can you give us a little sample
or is that going to get in yeah we have
to hear it now even though we're singing
i went into the bedroom and i was like
estas
and then that's what she's building
actually yeah and then they play like
usually it's like mariachi that's
playing it for you in your bedroom wait
they bring yes a band into your room
mexican people have mariachis for any
reason whatsoever
if you're trying to serenade a woman
that you like like you're trying to yeah
mariachi outside her window it's a must
really and she has to have a balcony
well he just shook his head no big time
big
time without ever giving me a mariachi
have you noticed with the national
anthem too there's kind of a carve out
where if they if they get to the land of
the free and they hit that note everyone
just starts clapping and you don't even
have to know the rest of the words yeah
you can just close it out from there
yeah the singer that i was done yeah
everyone just starts going
oh yeah but and jessica is here and then
me tiff as per usual yes yes what are we
talking about today tim all right jess
or is it jessica today because you look
pretty hot i got the brand names in full
effect and i got the red lipstick cool
shirt by the way yeah
i mean i don't know i've never i don't
know even how this got on my body do you
know how this got on my body
yeah um the last time a shirt that cool
and that sexy got on my body is when i
went on the big mood website and i
bought their merch because it just so
happens that that shirt is our merch and
when i wore that i had men and women
throwing their genitals at me oh
goodness that is a real review in real
time consensually genitals will fly to
you if you want them to if not you could
say no and they won't check the box no
yeah
just in case you guys can't make out
what her shirt says it says no matter
what phase you're always whole so that's
a little call back to something we've
said in in uh the show which is like
that one phrase that i learned from this
yoga teacher and coined this i mean it's
i feel like a lot of people have kind of
said it but we really liked it i
actually tried looking up like who the
actual it's not clear it's yeah it's
like unknown us it's us now yeah that's
nice
yeah we're claiming it and also we're
going to have sweatshirts so yes in
different color sweatshirts with our
name and stuff so one out of every 100
orders i drag my vagina across the shirt
for
my pheromones so good luck you don't
even know where the goddamn warehouse is
how long how long do you drag it across
uh it depends
a full frontal swipe it depends on how
big the sweater is like if they order
like an extra large i can only go about
halfway it only lasts there's a full
snail trail on one out of every 100
sweaters so
anyway buy several
jessica let me answer your question
because you asked
you're getting one yeah yeah yeah
all right so today we're talking about
uh the things that men have shared that
they didn't know
about women until they lived with them
oh okay yeah so every guy hasn't had a
mom i mean or a sister or something i
mean that's a living you don't [ __ ] your
mom at hope
it's different when you're [ __ ] them
so you feel like so i mean you have a
sister a sister
you have eight oh my god oh god our
audience you just won
our audience is not going to get that
okay
that is a terrible joke running joke
that steve has at his sister's hot and
he wants to [ __ ] his sister but it's
obviously a joke
right i guess obviously
a joke
um but yes so you have a sister and a
mom so i feel like you're very familiar
with women but when you moved in with
nikki were there things that surprised
you about living with a woman we're to
show a picture of
steve's sister and it's just mikey with
slightly longer hair
she's like oh this makes sense now with
blonde hair yeah yeah
yeah no uh it's funny because i actually
first moved in with my with a girlfriend
when i moved to l.a and it was like me
her and then my buddy jason horton and
we all moved to la together and i got my
first taste of what it's like to live
with a chick that you're [ __ ] then
and it was very strange because she was
a very messy person
and i also am a messy person and so it
was just a [ __ ] nightmare oh my god
it was like a hoarder castle already and
i just moved out of a hoarder castle
yeah so your parents were hoarders yeah
yeah casey's uh previous relationship
with before meeting me they were both
like ah
it looked crazy yeah it looked like
hoarders actually
yeah and this chick like it looked like
she lived in her car but she didn't live
in her car and so i was like why do you
have to look like you live in your car
yeah very weird
but she did not want to change it she
was like had her little system of like
you know she does outfit changes during
the day and stuff and well so that's not
really something surprising about living
into the gender that's just someone
being messy and you're awesome yeah
compatibility so it just added up for
sure but that's part of it right it's
like you know if you i used to clean
sometimes it's funny because when you're
a messy person but you're with a messier
person
you're you have to be the cleaner person
and so i used to clean as like a
surprise when she was gone
and it was like impossible to do it take
like 17 hours to do
and then when she got
home she would wreck it all again so
fast that i was like what was the
[ __ ] point of this [ __ ] um the point
is that so mold doesn't grow so roaches
don't create a nest there is a purpose
to cleaning even when you are hoarder
that's i should hear that more i really
should yeah yeah that's helpful but
living with women though it is it is a
different thing when between like you
know being with your sister and your mom
like because you're with this person you
can't just yell at them like you could
your sister
like or she yells back at you you can't
just go [ __ ] you like
like
can you clean your [ __ ]
like how hard is it you can't do any of
that right you have to be more like
tactful about things well i think that's
just something you do because i've lived
with guys that just say whatever the
[ __ ] like clean your [ __ ] or whatever so
that's just that that's why you're just
a nice guy yeah you're just a nice guy
but yeah no exactly so because i want to
keep with these people i had to try to
be tactful about it so it's not easy but
then there's also patterns that you you
pick up that i also find
is is interesting like women have such
small socks
especially in ankle
then until i say that they're like holy
[ __ ] have you had baby socks though i
recently saw baby ankle socks oh
my god
my mind is blown we're going to need it
oh my god oh super impose this picture
of a baby sock yeah you go to make it
about be a mom again i've never had my
kids it's not my kid but look look i've
never seen an ankle sock on a baby oh
that's cute oh my god it's so small
adorable
they have the weirdest legs ever kids
are so [ __ ] dumb it looks like
poultry
why do you want to eat that baby well it
has that interesting like fat around it
where you're like that i can see it dude
after my surgery i had baby hands oh my
god yeah because it's swollen yeah you
have like the dimples where your
knuckles are supposed to happen
it was swollen as [ __ ] whenever i made a
fist it looked like a baby fish and i
would get angry looking at my own nose
it's so funny it looked like that
kristen wiig snl sketch where she had
the tiny hand but yeah exactly the
opposite yeah and then like my foot was
so swollen it had no curves it was just
a straight you didn't you had straight
cankles yeah i had candles it was white
it was straight from her knee to her
toes
same with the cap
same with from her kneecaps to her toes
it's like someone drew you
all right so let's hop into this uh list
here so the first one says women pee
with a pressure hose i still get a
little scared when i hear a girl have a
good person it sounds like she's boring
i'm pouring a hole through the toilet
boring a whole do you think girls be
loud [ __ ] yeah yeah you guys got some
stream but i feel like guys be laughing
because there's so much gravity by the
time it hits the toy it's like
therapy is more like
and we're like
yeah my uncle i'm not my uncle sorry my
uh my cousin i think what he knows
my cousin walked by the bathroom because
he was like i need to use a bathroom and
then i was like wait let me pee real
quick and he's like you sound like a
[ __ ] super soaker when you pee
i was like really i guess do you push
really hard i'm like no it's just how i
pee i think i do push a little
push right i don't think i don't think
you're going like yeah
but like when you pee you're pushing you
are pushing it out you're not just like
letting it fall you're pushing a little
uh
you don't just sit down and it falls out
i know you don't just sit down and it
falls out i don't think i've really
thought about it
go pee again
you use your pelvic floor to pee
yes this is great i know you do nikki's
off camera no i don't know
i haven't gotten this so
she has an incontinence okay you're
looking you're like your old shriveled
little dog chihuahua you're like an 18
year old 45 year old why is your vagina
dude but this p thing though so i never
really realized but when like right now
talking about it it kind of unlocked a
memory with my ex like he used to live
with his mom and so like whenever we
would go over to his house like i kind
of like have to sneak into his his house
and so his parents didn't know that i
was there and so
when i had to go pee like after sex and
stuff cause i'm like i'm not trying to
get a uti he would actually
like try to turn on the the faucet
because he was like yeah girls pee
differently like they're gonna know it's
a girl peeing i'm like huh like they're
all sitting there listening to the peace
treaty i know it's also in the middle of
the night like your parents are not
because it was like the parents room and
then the bathroom
no then he was a very astute man he was
a yeah we never got caught yeah that was
a good method yeah there's this uh meme
that i saw recently that said women
peeing sounds like chicken frying and i
feel like it does sound like it's
like the popping oil of chicken frying
it sounds like a girl
it sounds like something's going on for
sure like it sounds like really powerful
i don't know because whenever i like
hear like casey p for example he pees
really strong too and it's like it's
also like the the water noises it's like
plopping yeah yeah you guys have plowed
it's coming from a lot farther away so
it sounds pretty loud
yeah well it's not that far away you
know what i'm saying
[Music]
she sets me up she hates me
i dated a guy where is it normal like
you got like i i've you guys have
different p streams like some guys pee
all the way through some guy has to
oh he got some he got some dick problems
yeah yeah
is he having no he's having something my
roommate was like that his name was
jason horton he was like that
[Music]
yeah
it was very odd
at all wait why do you know how he like
how do you know this is so much you can
hear we lived in a small town apartment
really you know you can hear so do you
pee like just straight through no stops
i mean not to brag but yeah oh how about
you towards the end you kind of like
stop
even i stopped yeah
yeah yeah it's a little stuttered at the
end
but then for for in the beginning though
the whole like thing like it's fine and
then the end is when you actually start
strong he loses his confidence oh okay
got it got it got it got it it's kind of
like shaking don't you have to like
shake it don't you guys have to shake
[ __ ] that's why yeah no i'm curious i
want to call that guy up and be like hey
you might want to get that checked yeah
what was wrong with him again right now
no there was like it was just the the
the stream was always stop and go and
then stop and go you should call my
friend jason horton
i'll get jason horton's phone number
later if you have jason where i got it
if i was
oh dating god
if i was dating a guy and he had that
kind of p stream i would immediately go
get an std test
yeah
fyi no he didn't have anything though
okay but we don't know that jason didn't
yeah
all right next one on the list is it
says it took me a while to figure out
that pads are stuck onto the panties as
opposed to the right on the
vagina dude i actually thought this too
when i was little
but i was really little like
it makes sense why we would know because
we have to use them yeah but then
recently like not that
long ago there was another person in my
life that knew thought this exact same
thing and i couldn't stop laughing
that's hilarious and it's like the glue
is in the front and we just put it on
the vagina oh my god that's funny have
you ever seen a girl have to put a pad
on have you yeah of course
you've watched a girl have her panties
down and put a pad on i've seen them put
it drop it in the underwear and then
pull it up yeah for sure when you live
with women i mean [ __ ] happens in life
yeah you know you see horrors that you
never wish
you never you wish
this is our everyday life i know i i
don't i do that you know i'm not gonna
do that thing though where i go man
girls you got it tough and all this [ __ ]
everyone says that yeah i just you know
yeah live with it okay deal with it have
you ever seen a girl insert a tampon
never do you know how a tampon works i
think there's an applicator okay which
is basically they should just call it
like you just put it in there but then
yeah you and then you leave it in there
i guess oh in france okay so you clearly
no it's like space right where if you're
gonna if you're gonna get in there you
have to leave something behind yeah yeah
do you know the mechanics of the tampon
you push it in and then you pull out the
rest of it but you leave the thing how
do you how do you push it you're docking
in the space station how do you push it
in it's almost like with the applicator
dumbass
if you can describe the actual process
she already did the movement the hand
gesture of what you should do you know
obviously the italian way yeah
i don't know have you guys ever used
those the one that doesn't have and i
saw it in france i saw it in france i
was like what is this basket full of
tampons with no applications
yeah i guess they just shut down up
there and they're just dude weird yeah
and mexico they use those too and one
time i was vacationing out there with
family and i didn't have a tampon on me
and my aunt gave me one it was like a
tiny little thing and i was like what am
i supposed to do with this and she goes
just wing it yeah she was just like you
just use your finger and i was like oh
yeah it's strange very strange yeah you
should see how
there's like a there's like a rubber cup
and then you have to fold it so they
fold the cup and you shove it in and the
cup pops open and then it's like a
little a little um a little
uh rubber
tail that hangs out and then if you want
to get the cup out you have to stick
your finger in unsuction the cup so you
gotta like oh that's how you collapse
part of the cup and then pull it out and
then a whole [ __ ] cup full of blood
spills all over the toilet it's
fantastic and tissue they're not fun
it's like a murderer glad i asked thank
you very much
cups are not okay well before we um you
know make steve extremely sick to his
stomach we'll move on to
a word
don't move on to a word from our sponsor
blah blah blah anyways um noom is a
healthy habit weight loss app and um i
think it's actually been a bit helpful
for me i i go back and forth from like
trying to lose weight to not trying
anymore
and i think sometimes it's the habit
that i have of being just [ __ ] lazy
and also i get really um lonely and so i
start snacking extra at home sometimes
or if i'm drinking then i'm like i need
the tacos and so what what newm does
though really it helps you like kind of
take a look at your personality your
habits and then it helps you with the
psychology based on on why you do the
things you do as far as your health and
stuff like that so it's a psychology
based approach to help us change our
mindset for good because building better
habits means a more sustainable journey
sometimes people use really
crappy weight loss methods like extreme
calorie deficient um
[Music]
diets that are so unhealthy like eat
only 600 calories a day
and you know that [ __ ] doesn't last like
you're gonna swing you're gonna get fat
and skinny and fat and skinny and your
body's just going to be wrecked on the
inside so those are really unhealthy
methods eighty percent of newm users
have finished the program and over sixty
percent have stuck with their goals for
at least a year start building better
habits for healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com big
mood that's in oom dot com slash big
mood
again sign up for your trial go to
noom.com
big mood
yeah you know what's really useful on
your period
of a day
oh my gosh yes
yeah because you need to rinse that keep
it clean oh yeah
uh it's not only for cleaning your butt
but you can clean all the blood off of
you too that's where hello tishi comes
in if you got poop on any other part of
your body would you just wipe it off no
no it's weird wash that right you'd wash
it so stop wiping and start washing with
hello tishi the modern bidet that
attaches directly to your toilet
um hello tissue is the modern bidet for
people who poop because everybody poops
i like the word poop
it's fun to say
it washes your butt with water for a
better clean than toilet paper um so
that means every poop is a one wipe poop
and washing with water is less
irritating and more soothing for your
butthole it's also easy to install you
don't need um to plug it into anything
it attaches in under 10 minutes no
plumbing needed
using a hello tissue bidet also reduces
your toilet paper used by 80 saving you
money in the long run it's also
eco-friendly and stylish halo tissue
also has a full product line to help
make the restroom the best place in your
house they have a hella tissue ottoman
it's the sleekest toilet stool designed
to help you poop at 100
100 of the time it's rated number one by
wire cutter there's also a hello tissue
brush it's the only toilet brush with
disposable scrubbing pads so you can use
a clean brush every time i i always felt
weird about those brushes you scrub the
poop off you put it back and then it's
still oh yeah
it doesn't make sense to me so start
washing with a hell tissue body for a
better clean go to healthtissy.com
big mood to get 10 off plus free
shipping this is a special offer for our
listeners
go to hellotishie.com big mood for ten
percent off and after you buy it uh show
it off tag us
at
hellotischee on instagram not your butt
we don't see your butt but just show us
the installation show us everything all
right well
all right so the next one on this list
is actually you know like with the topic
of of periods they wrote i never
realized just how much blood comes out
of a woman on her period until i walked
in on my girlfriend taking a shower i
honest i honestly thought she was dying
and bleeding out yeah not that much
comes out though really like if you've
seen the study like they'll they'll try
to it's actually not all they'll try to
capture the period of a girl and like
it's like a third of it it's not that
big but don't have the heavy flow i know
yeah there is yeah but it's still like
it's not gonna be a whole [ __ ] cup
a cup full you know like an eight ounce
cup full it's not that much mine was
heavier when i was younger like when i
was younger i had to wear overnight pads
every night or else i'll leak onto the
bed yeah i remember my first period was
super heavy
um like when i was younger i had a lot
more blood and a lot more pain like my
back actually hurt a lot my fupa ached
all the time
but then now are you on birth control
now no
oh see mine is the opposite it was it
hurt not at all when i was on birth
control and now that i've been off for
several years it hurts more now yeah
that's crazy
we were going on a cruise and she
basically had a baby in front of me oh
my god yeah i'm not kidding it was crazy
wait like so was she pregnant or she
just blended no no she she bled out she
yeah she blew it out
she was like yeah no she was rude it was
very strong
[Music]
like in the pool no i was walking with
her and then she
you know
had her
but i was like couldn't happen at a
better time going on a [ __ ] carnival
yeah did it go through her um clothes
and everything no she had yoga pants on
thankfully very tight
were they were they like white
thankfully for me but thankfully for her
yeah you saw the blood then or what
happened no no she was telling me about
it like live giving me like a
play-by-play like a football game yeah
it was crazy you know that scene he was
there oh really so you know that scene
from um uh [ __ ] the shining where
like the yeah that's all the blood
coming down the hallway that's what the
gushing i remember my flow was so heavy
that when when i inked really hard like
the pad wouldn't even soak it up fast
enough oh yeah and it leaks out yeah
what the heck is jeff's talking about
you get a little thimble full
yeah well i mean it's really not that
much yeah it looks like a lot because
it's just on on this little area but
it's really not that i mean it's not an
eight ounce cup full to me that's a lot
of blood that's a lot it's gonna be less
than a cup worth so it's not that much
have you guys periods gotten shorter as
you've gotten older yeah right mine used
to be like full five days now it's like
three minutes yeah
not mine oh but i love how we're making
steve sit here
i lived around men less than women
actually because my dad was never home
thanks
dad gonna uncomfortable back us that's
why you fell in love with your sister
well you had to go somewhere for love
don't you yeah
yeah
okay we can get off the period yeah all
right next i'm sure the other guys are
uh zexton says that decorative pillows
are a thing you carefully choose and
purchase them just so you can spend the
rest of your life pushing them out of
the way and occasionally cleaning them i
know you guys agree so hard
whoever wrote this is a genius that is
so [ __ ] true i've never seen more
decorative pillows in my whole goddamn
life you don't enjoy your home being a
whole insanity bro you don't enjoy your
house being decorated like a goddamn
[ __ ] hotel very thankful about that
she did a great job it's amazing but
even where poor casey's sitting it was
covered in [ __ ] decorative pillows
and the couch is covered in decorations
what's wrong with the bed covered in the
bed looks so cool oh by the way you just
the shelf that you always climb into and
when you stay here
[Applause]
and then they close it and i sleep in
there like
it's so covered in decorative pillows
it's disturbing that's the point though
of a day bed like a trundle bed the
whole top layer is supposed to be
covered in [ __ ] decorative pillows
and your wife is on the outside of this
set right now right back
that's the thing that i can't get into
yet because you guys know how i told you
like i can't decorate or anything
because i don't like buying things that
aren't useful useful i love that yeah
see like like that hexagon thing there
what the [ __ ] is that or like it's like
a so you want us to be handled you want
to see that what's this i agree what is
this
i get it because it's for decorations
sterile blank white walls around you i
love decorations it's just that i hate
spending my own money on it like people
you're not gonna see you're gonna spend
your husband's money on it you're not
gonna shoot your money on it's true like
why do we have a water is that no
it's a candle hey that's that's the one
behind you is worse
it's just because it's inspirational
you purchase things for happiness they
created an environment stupid you're
just like yourself it looks great i get
it it reminds me of a soccer ball i hate
soccer and this i don't even know what
the [ __ ] this is it's like a sea urchin
you don't want to step on this yeah
i get that it's for decorative stuff but
i just i can't buy things just for
decoration i have to it has to have some
sort of function but you have like a
[ __ ] anime rug that serves no but
it's a rug
to keep my feeties warm uh-huh you know
untie the room
okay well that makes it a little bit
better you know but it's like throw a
pill like you have she has like 16
blankets you know and then everything
looks great how many people are in this
room what if we all needed a blanket
right now nikki's got a whole basket
full of blankets i will say in her
defense we swiped some from the friends
premiere thing
i totally jacked them absolutely
i have an absurd amount of
pillows and blankets too in my house
like i actually have pillows in the
garage because i don't know what to do
with them there's so many donate them we
swiped some of these from the friends
thing too right uh these two yeah these
two yeah or like you know like white
people over there behind her too mason
jars yeah yeah like i'll see mason jars
filled with like buttons oh that's a
purpose it's called someone's sewing
room
no it's just in the kitchen like you
don't even sell like it's just amazing
people do you know
with weird things white people usually
have craft rooms
my dad has mason jars in his house a lot
but he makes his own salsa and he puts
them in the mason jar so they're useful
we do we use the mason jars for things
we drink [ __ ] sweet tea full of ice i
sweet tea out of the mason jars
if you put anything in the mason jar i
think it's cooler than it ever deserves
to be it's so old-school and cute all
right next one basic women are always
cold always yeah i know i'm wearing
shorts all the time [ __ ] you're gonna be
sweating and shorts and a t-shirt but my
significant other will be wrapped in
blankets still
nikki said that's why we have 16
blankets but no i have a friend named
erica who i used to work at maker
studios with and basically she would
what's your last name just kidding
she would she would basically like lay a
blanket on the floor grab the corner and
then roll herself up and do it and then
get in her desk every single day she was
the coldest chick i've ever seen there
was like a whole thing going on about
women uh saying that men in office
buildings keep the temperature too low
because they their bodies run yes hotter
than ours do with all the testosterone
and [ __ ] so obviously we're just not
living in the same ecosystem we're not
we don't have the same people we don't
have the same we don't burn so hot you
know what i'm saying well i think we all
have the same bodies
oh okay
i suppose that's science
but i actually feel hot a lot now i'm
like am i going through [ __ ] early
menopause because i'm always [ __ ] hot
it's well there's light it is hot right
now um you know currently it's 99
degrees also i just moved to texas so
i'm like i'm always like oh my god i'm
so hot it's so hot everywhere it goes
like 90 always yeah yeah yeah i sleep
hot like i wake up just on fire yeah
yeah yeah i run hot i i could be i could
be sweating in the middle of the night
but i always have to have like that thin
sheet over me yes i can't i can't sleep
without being covered yeah me too even
if it's just like my knee it's just like
a small thin little thing protective
exactly i have to have a foot out no
matter what
no matter if it's cold as [ __ ] or
anything i have to have a foot out not
me but the one thing i do like is you
know when your leg hairs get you shave
and your legs are getting pokey oh wait
never mind no no that too but when your
leg hairs get pokey i always have to
[ __ ] like
stick the the blankets between my legs
so that i don't have to touch my own
[ __ ] leg hairs you know i've been
sleeping with the pillow between my legs
for a few years now and i recently got a
pregnancy pillow so it's like a u-shape
so i'm like literally in a cocoon
i guess i'll [ __ ] myself no
it's a [ __ ] six foot six and a half
foot pillow candy cane it's bigger than
me we were carrying it in here casey
[ __ ] two men carrying it in like like
it's a piano
[ __ ] crazy they replaced your husband
basically these are facts yeah
now if all right
like honestly i mean i don't even need
it right now because i don't know
anywhere right now just like sleeping in
it i'm like i'm never gonna get one i
don't have a man to hold me so maybe i
should get a pillow girl it feels so
bomb um here comes the comments to your
rescue yeah yeah
i'll hold you every single night
i swear to god
i can't wait for that no but yeah you
just lower your [ __ ] standards a
little bit yeah
oh
yeah sure i live in a shoe
but like you know [ __ ] lower
standards down a little bit yeah yeah
all right next one uh
that women have magically regenerating
hair otherwise my girlfriend should be
bald judging by the amount of hair she
leaves around the apartment
yes everyone's hair falls but what about
hair on the fridge here in the fridge is
one of the most hair in the fridge
they're in the fridge the strangest
[ __ ] thank you how do you get hair in
the fridge
she knows hold on she knows she gets
hair in the fridge first of all her old
man i said man what about the hair in
the fridge and he gave me a look and
he's like jesus christ you you you
understand somebody understand it's your
problem you started shaking me he's like
you understand somebody understand it
was crazy i've never seen hair have you
found have you found her hair on your
ass crack yet no oh really what do you
do well it makes sense it's in our ass
crack because we're washing the shower i
mean why would it be in my eyes we sleep
naked together oh you're never new never
mind that's right never mind he said
never know what i'm gonna never eat my
butt too yeah yeah yeah so that helps no
one else is talking about that but okay
well that was that was one scenario
maybe where your hair could get in there
yeah do you keep your underwear on so
that no one will touch your ass yeah i
keep two on two underwear two underwears
one chastity belt
the hair in the fridge though yeah nikki
somehow gets hair in the fridge it's odd
also whenever we go to hotels anytime
and i don't even think she's taking a
shower yet there's like a swirly nicky
hair
on the stuck to the wall i'm like she
didn't even take a shower yet what the
[ __ ] is going on huh is somebody
pranking me
like it's crazy but she has a swirly she
takes her hair and then she like swirls
it up and puts it on the wall for me why
do you [ __ ] swirl your hair
oh it's for later you have a lot of hair
yeah your hair's really dude i make it
into a ball as i'm showering like it's
just like a tiny little ball that i add
more to that little ball and then i
throw that little ball crazy i don't do
any of that i let it cover the drain and
then i just pick it up at the end i see
hair coming out and i'm like oh please
come back
no get back on there oh
every follicle it's okay they have a
surgery if you really needed it i'll get
there but right now i'm looking for sick
entries on crypto
[Laughter]
co-host said g4 he got hair [ __ ] done
and it's so crazy that it ended up
giving him black eyes
yeah
the whole process he just it's just
random bruising he had black eyes i
heard you have to take time off and like
your face swells and all kinds of [ __ ]
so yeah i'll be doing it eventually i'm
definitely going to do it i'm not
ashamed to say it i think elon did it
like a bunch of people did it and it
looks really good
steve carell yeah steve crawled in
mcconaughey had a shitty ass hairline
too yeah yeah
dang nope yeah like the whole thing
about girls like leaving their hair
everywhere i actually have to contest
that because my husband leaves way more
hair than i do really a lot of hair
though he's got that the caramel
man's hair
literally you look at our bed and you
know exactly where casey sleeps oh
it's all [ __ ] hair yeah he sheds a lot
yeah you be thankful got such a healthy
hairline you could be stuck with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like me got shitty ass
hairline see no let me complain about it
let me complete all right because i have
to sleep with my hair
my hair's really fine and it's you can't
really see it so i don't think you
notice it that means your child has the
best hair odds you know how my child's
hair odds are going to be
50 50 right now 50 50. horrible hair
odds yeah you both you guys have really
good hair the white is recessive though
so is it the white jean is pretty
recessive every time there's a mixed
child
most of the time it doesn't look like a
white or it doesn't really have like a
lot of the white jeans so like the blue
eyes will probably be gone you know the
thin hair will probably be gone freckles
will probably be oh nicki's saving this
bloodline i think he's saving this
bloodline yeah our eyesight will be gone
i've heard it all before but all of my
nieces and nephews are redheads so i'm
scared guys i'm scared what it's true
what's your brother-in-law or redheads
all of it oh wow it's all redheads guys
wait what do you mean your sister well
my brother-in-law's a redhead no but
your sister she's she's in strawberry
blonde well if they're yeah well yeah
that's two reds what do you mean
[Laughter]
here's the thing there's a lot of
inbreeding in my family
all right next one it says i was about
19 or 20 when i learned women wipe after
they pee it's not that it didn't make
sense to me i just had never
i just never had a reason to even
consider it as a thing so i was quite
dumbfounded when i saw it happen and
another one says like women use a lot of
toilet paper yes a lot yeah not unless
you have a bidet yeah exactly wait do
you guys because i use way more toilet
paper than nicky and she goes [ __ ]
ape about it why do you use so much when
he poops yeah why when i when i poop
because i like to be very very clean but
do you guys also need it
maybe you should try shaving your
[ __ ] i do all kinds of manscaping you
understand uh-huh i don't want to knock
the plug in that no one ever gets to see
because he's never needed wait till
fully out
excuse me
wait wait until your poop is fully out
out then there's less behind oh i like
to wipe as i go
that way
does she think it's happening yeah
i dropped one and i'm like i still got
more but i better wipe this better wipe
in between yeah
i meant like like not even drop the
whole thing he cuts it off halfway
continues
to be very clean there needs to be a
clean slate for every poop every
damn really you have to change a role
like every day listen i'm a [ __ ]
definitely get a bidet then for sure
they have one pillow here
we have one
it's not
they have three bathrooms in this house
so it's not in his office
you should definitely use it thanks for
flexing on our bathroom situation you do
have three bathrooms
yes
but women do use a lot of toilet paper
like i um
when when my my sister or we have guests
stay over
the toilet paper consumption goes up
like [ __ ] crazy like i have to go
resupply my toilet paper all the time
costco members
yeah yeah we have more uses for it we
use it for makeup and [ __ ] too like you
know just like little things whatever
throughout the day we we use toilet
paper more i wipe and then fold and wipe
them
are you a square person you do the fully
fold fold yeah oh you guys know what i
do i rip exactly five of pieces off
every single time and then i pop each
square off what so i have five
like sheets papers are stacked yeah i
don't fold it i just rip off five not
even on purpose but i is i grab it and
it reaches to a certain point and it's
exactly five squares every year i count
it every day and i pop no i just noticed
after a while i was like how many
squares am i using i noticed every
single time it's five and then i
pop them apart separately stack them on
top of each other and that is one white
[ __ ] weirdo we can edit that out if
you want no no yeah yeah i think we will
do this
we got your back here yeah yeah we got
you i i i grab them and then i roll
around my hands
i don't [ __ ] wipe with my knuckles
why do i need toilet paper on the back
of my knuckles
yeah and then i fold it yeah and then i
use the other side and then i take my
hand out of the loopy loop and then i
fold it yeah that's what i do i think
that's what 99 people do you don't need
to you don't need to wrap your hand with
it you could just [ __ ] layer them
pull your five squares individually yeah
that's a lot right it's not look i'll
[ __ ] take you upstairs and show
yourself because that takes so much
longer for it to
fold this way and then that way and then
this way and then that way what about i
just popped them all off what about the
shitty toilet papers that like if you
can't what do you want yeah that you
can't even like tear off into the square
i've never i'm not around such shitty
toilet paper well you should go to the
commerce casino
you guys later i have a stack of toilet
paper in my hand you just grip it like
this it's easy you guys want to watch me
i mean i guess it makes sense because
like after i finish folding and i wipe
and then i i mean i fold it and then i
wipe it
can we just get a roll please do we need
to do a demonstration oh am i flying a
roll why don't you just hold it instead
of ripping i don't need to fold it
folding it takes longer because if it if
the fold is not exactly you need a paper
clip
i
if the fold is not exactly on the line
it's going to piss me off that is
wrong that's the reason why i have to
[ __ ] rip them apart and stack them i
love you so much because you make me
feel normal yeah yeah yeah you make me
feel normal because i'm [ __ ] weird
dude
yeah i have crazy ocd like even just
earlier like steve was trying to put his
his drink on this table and i was like
oh yeah if you just move that that uh
plant you could fit it but he moved it
where he turned it
and there's there's lettering on the
other side of that of the vase or the
pot thing so i was like no i got to turn
it so i'm like i'm [ __ ] weird like
that i've never used toilet paper like
that before that's so interesting
someone in the comments will have to
agree with me that they rip off some
well i remember i it was all the way up
until i was a teenager that i used to
just grab it crumple it up and just wipe
and then i was like why the [ __ ] am i
doing this but i always used to crumple
yeah i used to crumple when i was little
too but you know what though
speaking of uh going and using the
restroom and pooping and all that
sometimes i like to listen to music
do you you listen to music while you
fancy or if it's not music i'll listen
to audiobooks and i'll learn as i'm
pooping
or what audiobooks so well i'm not going
to get into the audio books but i will
tell you i will tell you who's over back
then
great song great job great one of my top
five yeah
i will tell you though i use my raycon
so shout out to our sponsor raycon which
are wireless earbuds
and i honestly just jamming out on the
toilet
dude and also okay raycons like these
these earbuds are my absolute favorite
i've never owned like other pair like
i've only ever had like headphones so
they're all really like heavy i used to
have like you know the wired ones those
are annoying the wire gets in the way
but these raycons are like my first ever
wireless earbuds and they're so cute and
small and they actually perfectly fit
into my ear so you know how like with
other ones they'll have like like the
little stick that comes out and it'll
get like caught in your stuff like it's
caught on my sweater all the time and
yeah it flies across the room yeah well
do you have to worry about that with
raycon
and also they come with a whole bunch of
different gel tips for your comfort
because you know everyone has different
ear holes they also have a 32-hour
battery life that is insane
it's so crazy like you can listen to
things forever like a really long flight
actually like two long flights
and it's really cool too because they
immediately connect to my phone like i
don't actually have to like
open bluetooth and try to connect it or
whatever pair it no it immediately pairs
to my phone
and like if i want to use one of the
earbuds or the other they just are
really good with the connectivity i'm
really impressed by that they also start
at half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good and
raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you really can't lose give
them a try you'll see what i mean
create your own soundtrack with raycon
right now our listeners can get fifteen
percent off their recon order at buy
raycon dot com slash big mood that's by
raycon dot com big mood to save 15
on ray cons by recon dot com slash big
mood yes and another shout out to
another sponsor feels which is premium
cbd
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel like stress anxiety
or pain and feels is a better way to
feel better i've actually been using cbd
in a variety of ways and we've faced
fields sent us some and i've been trying
it out um but another way i used to use
it a lot was a roll-on for headaches on
my face and it has like menthol and cpd
in it it's really great and i so i like
the feels because i can also ingest it
as well feels is a premium cbd that will
help keep your head clear and feel your
best it's hassle-free delivered directly
to your door and naturally helps to
reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness and there's no hangover or
addiction you just place a few drops of
fields under your tongue and you'll feel
the difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose is important and
everyone's dose is different
in fact feels offers a free cbd hotline
to help guide your personal experience
so that you find your perfect dose the
fields customer service team is
dedicated to making sure you get the
best use of your cbd joining field's
monthly membership makes your self-care
easy you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel any time
start feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com big
mood and you'll get 50 percent off your
first order with free shipping that's
fields.com big mood to become a member
and get 50
automatically taken off your first order
with free shipping deals dot com slash
big mood all right the next one on this
list really [ __ ] threw me off
what let me know if you guys agree with
this because i don't this one says i did
not realize that women plucked the hair
out of their nipples i was shocked yeah
i don't have hair on my nipples yeah
what so i used to not have hair on my
nose at all but then like you guys know
how i'm a huge advocate of wearing just
sticky bras uh-huh i feel like wearing
that a lot made me grow like nipple
so i'll just have like one per nipple
that's just like really dark and what
the [ __ ] is this but then i just like
pluck it out whoa
plain sticky bras so sticky brows are
exactly like uh think of like fabric
cups they're kind of firm fabric cups
and they're it's just sticky on one side
and i just slap it on there and it's
thick i like the cutlets thing yeah yeah
the cutlets add a thick
girth to your tit but there's also just
sticky bras that are literally just
fabric and sticky so it just it's like
having a bra just stuck to the front so
that's why you need them to stick to you
no straps i'm wearing a backpack
whatever and i don't need like anything
that lifts because my boobies are fake
so i just slap them on so my nipples
aren't just protruding everywhere i
actually use nipple covers which is the
same thing but it's just like a smaller
version of that and it just sticks on
then for me like you can still see the
shape of the nipple cover yeah i don't
like those oh you gotta get the ones i
get they're really good because i've
tried other ones they suck i've never
found one that doesn't [ __ ] make a
very clear circle in my shirt and it
looks like i have bigger [ __ ] nipples
than i do exactly these aren't like
it depends on the fabric that you use
when you're wearing them but yeah mine
for the most part the only reason i
would get those would be for a very thin
fabric and then it shows through
something like they'll definitely show
and plus the sticky ones you don't feel
the straps and all the constraints of
everything it's really comfy yeah but no
i don't i maybe that's a hormonal thing
maybe some women do have some i mean if
you look very closely to my nipple
there's like the tiniest little peach
fuzz right but my entire body's covered
in that yeah but i don't have nipple
hairs and i've never [ __ ] plucked
nipple hairs yeah i've never plucked
maybe that's just hormonal for some
girls maybe they have never had that
their whole life and then like gina
something creates that or like menopause
or something but i like that's not like
normal they're too new gina they don't
they haven't grown you knew they're too
new they're two there's like one
no
let me see me because now now that i'm
pregnant i have noticed i'm getting like
hairier like the little hairs here on on
the sides like they're getting darker
and then also the hair lines yeah like
my the hair on my stomach too
and around like my eyes they're starting
to get darker i'm like oh this is what
pregnancy does what's the biggest change
for you being pregnant right now sorry
to
um it's too early for her it is really
too early but
she's not yet first oh my still 11 weeks
right now but by the time this comes out
i will be in my second trimester anyway
um i mean the nausea has just been
unbearable
nausea has been whack the [ __ ] sense
of smell has been like i have a
superpower really i can everything's
like super
sensitive um
i don't know there's like yeah it's kind
of still early but okay ask me like okay
next time i'm gonna bug you don't worry
about it ask me the next one i have do
you guys have like a random hair that
grows yes
one i have like two chin hairs like
[ __ ] constantly i have to pluck them
because they're weird on your cheeks on
my cheeks
it's just one on each side yeah randomly
out of a yeah here it's been like this
since high school i was like whatever
that was pretty weird i plucked them
like every two days because they have
they
[Laughter]
when they do graphics like can you pull
these yeah just put up here
pull the plug from my straight face hair
operator where the [ __ ] are you where
you been like mr potato head but with
hair yeah the operator died three years
ago where's your weird one i have one
weird one in the back of my shoulder
right here
yeah my my friend's like it's your angel
wings i was like it's a weird black wing
like that's one that grows out of a mole
somewhere because you know i've got that
shitty [ __ ] irish skin mine is in my
lower back on the right side of my lower
back and sometimes i'm taking a shower
i'm like is that [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
grow back
yeah cause it's like thick it's so weird
yeah also there's one right here on my
wrist it's
i only notice it but it sometimes that
grows extra darker than the rest because
all my my arm hairs are like really
blonde you see this one yeah very oh
yeah yeah i have a few on my arms that
are your arm whoa look at that [ __ ]
yeah that's always been there
that reminds me of my i have like this
[ __ ] little fatty thing i don't know
what this is it's like y'all want to
talk about protruding bones
stop it with your elbows check out these
elbows
wait that's it that's it
weirdos and then i used to have one
white thick hair that just grow on my
arm it was white like a silver i get a
white one in my eyebrows crazy i'm gonna
collect that one because it feels like
human bodies are so interesting strange
all right next one uh my bathroom
filling up with more niche and
unreasonably expensive hair and skin
care unreasonably [ __ ] [ __ ] up
available
[Laughter]
i find that that causes hair loss oh
yeah
i found out too late oh yeah i'm sorry
so you didn't use that forever oh the
whole time the whole i was using swag
swag don't even worry about it hair
facing feet and you're like all right
you know what the difference is um like
men's is actually like classified as
like detergent like the same way like
the [ __ ] we wash our clothes
it's like it's like corrosive detergent
it's what they put in men's products so
yeah we're not [ __ ] putting that [ __ ]
on our bodies sorry these are girl [ __ ]
yeah no chicks use a lot of products but
i understand why because i have like
obviously my wife does that but then my
friend jess lazama who i mentioned
earlier
she uses so many [ __ ] products it's
actually insane she's 40 but she looks
[ __ ] 20. that's what i'm saying she
looks like she's younger than her own
daughter her own daughter i think you
know maybe you know her own daughter is
beautiful
she's beautiful she's the best yeah
[ __ ] kidding
she was 11. yeah
but i just the proof's in the pudding
i'm saying like it works so yeah you can
fill your counter up and yeah the
counter does fill up by the way do you
like our [ __ ] soft skin do you like
our [ __ ] smelling good hair do you
like our soft lips
every single [ __ ] thing we do to make
you happy so don't [ __ ] complain
about the products on the counter you
know what let me undo everything you
just said because i want to complain
about myself i have an unreasonable
amount of [ __ ] products that i never
[ __ ] touch that's your fault
a lot of them
but also you get a lot of sponsorships
you get a lot of [ __ ] given to you for
free like we are not necessarily the
average
yeah
separate bathrooms is probably a good
idea
my vitamins expired in 2018. oh my god
and i was like oh that's why my body
looks like this no that's not right
i was like dude that's [ __ ] on the
vitamins so i got new vitamins guys so
i'm excited about it
yeah i got some 20 21 ones good for you
very excited about it
no no i'm ex
i'll check on that i'll check on that
they're gonna expire in three months i'm
excited to let you guys know the results
we'll keep an eye on your
hairline know what that does
you guys will be the first to know all
right next one it says when i first
moved in with my girlfriend i got yelled
at for putting dirty clothes with my
clean ones i was totally under the
impression i could wear that shirt like
two more times i must be a man because i
put my clothes back in like on the
hanger yeah i fold it back up after i
use it once yep and then i'll once i
realize like oh like if it's a shirt or
a dress like the armpit is filled with
like deodorant or something yeah i'm
like oh because i don't smell like i
never at least i can't smell my own
smell and
so like it's never gonna be dirty for me
like smell wise it's always gonna be
like a buildup of deodorant yeah i don't
know same way i don't wash it after
every wear because that's going to ruin
your clothes yeah so like my system is
um i have the chair in the room where
it's like it's not ready to be washed
yet but it's not clean enough to go back
in the closet so yeah i would never mix
them that's what's bothering yeah it
makes me [ __ ] mix it back in i like
them were we mixing
like clothes that have been worn with
brand new out of the out of the washer
yeah i don't believe in that but i do i
do believe in you can't wear the same
thing twice especially if you're a dude
because we have all kinds of glandular
things guys are really [ __ ] gross
yeah man you can smell
that's why gyms smell like that yeah
it's not because of chicks no ever yeah
that's so true yeah so it's i have like
a it's like the basket for the dirty
clothes the chair for the in the middle
clothes and then close it
i'll never we we wear any item of
clothing
like i have to wash it first but these
are sweaty
you guys are grody so it makes sense
yeah i don't i guess i don't have as
much of a problem as wearing something
again but mixing them with the clean
clothes that [ __ ] drives me insane i
can't believe that well jess don't ever
use it i'm not i'm not [ __ ] going to
your house
okay uh next one is i didn't realize
women lay in the bathtub with the faucet
running on their vagina to get off
[Laughter]
we got caught we've been there hasn't
everyone done that what what yeah [ __ ]
yeah how are you
[Music]
to the dress so the top of your butt
crack touches the drain
and you're i mean your legs are straight
up yeah cheeks against the wall not to
speak up for the comment section but i'm
sure there's a guy out there who's like
you don't have to do that anymore
i'll treat you like the queen that you
are you gotta use the foul set i don't
do that anymore now because like it's
not very eco-friendly and i actually i'm
old enough to purchase toys
i have toys that is a good point that
that's some young [ __ ] that's what you
do when you don't you can't buy it you
can't go online and buy toys forgive me
for the infancy of my mind but aren't
you guys just filling yourself up with
water yeah
yeah for me it is some will go in there
no because you have to angle it to hit
the cliff yeah
i mean yeah sure i guess but but then
you're just like being like pumped up
you know i don't know yeah that doesn't
feel good like for the stream to go
directly inside is not good yeah and
sometimes like a water balloon yeah yeah
yeah no
like sometimes we'll have like a delayed
um release so then like you know i get
changed afterwards and also it's like
extra man it got like caught up behind
the cervix or something and then it just
extra spills out this warm water it's
like you're waterproof you guys share
way more than my sister
this is like totally different but
that's a lot like when you're younger
like i don't think any of us now are
really probably resorting to that it's
the poor girl's firepower girl's
vibrator
no listen so i went to a water park a
couple years ago and like going down the
slide when i stood up it was like gushed
all out because it like got caught up in
there that's never happened to me
because i remember like they make you
like cross your legs and they didn't
make me cross my legs my legs were
crossed oh the [ __ ] water still like
going like from my backside yeah from
underneath so i'm like that it's the
landing for me sometimes because like
your legs aren't gonna you're not gonna
necessarily land with your legs crossed
so if you land all [ __ ] up because
you're like turn left turn right it's
like [ __ ] shaking around and then
your legs are wide open and then you
land in the water every time i got up
too i'm like does anyone notice
it's like your heart no because your
whole body is still at your vagina yeah
but she's standing there all of a sudden
you're
like my water broke my water broke yeah
extra extra gush
yeah that was intense but i'm glad that
we all can relate that's beautiful it's
like a double jump you know what's fun
that i envy guys for when i have my
boobies done you can't sit down and pee
because your body's so sore and [ __ ]
right like you can't bend over and wipe
i had to get the girl funnel dude that
thing is so nice to pee into what i want
to try girl funnel yeah there's a funnel
called the she
yeah and like it's a silicone thing that
molds like it's so nice like it's shaped
mold to your lady parts and then it's a
funnel that you that you aim it you take
it off where are your lips covered in
this
gorgeous big it's big like it's a big
like thing
yeah you still have to wipe though yeah
of course you have to wipe but then like
you don't have to sit to beating him
while i just picture the funnel filling
with urine because like the tube is not
going to be as wide
so like it's oh no it's a white enough
the cup is filling with your like
your vagina lips are just swimming in
pink i just want to see gina pitch it on
shark tank
if that's okay with you
hi sharks
my name's gina i'm from los angeles
california and i'm here to pitch to you
the shoe when i had surgery my best
friend was this
stupid corny video with it yeah dude no
you have someone whose soul is sucked
out of their body and they're like your
sidekick and they're demonstrating it
it's always that person yeah
all right and so for the last one here
it says in my 10 years living alone i
have never once needed to dump drano
down any of my drains they just never
get clogged with the short hairs that go
down the drains i have to dump drano
down the drain every four months or else
i'll get a lake in the shower okay well
that's a you problem because i don't
have to do that either mm-hmm yeah
i don't have to do that [ __ ] that's your
girlfriend's problem
it's your puppy i have hard water
that's why nikki circles it up and then
drags it across her shower wall and
cleans it up later
i have to say i i have to say
years ago
i was making fun of how nikki had a
toilet that was like black
and i was like this is [ __ ] up
i was like a man should never have to
see such a thing
and then we moved into this place and my
toilet has hard water too and i'm like i
should have just shut up
because i get it now my shower has hard
water and my toilet has water
those things get all caked up with all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah oh no you have to put
the thing in the toilet bowl like behind
the toilet bowl so that it always stays
like cleaning itself yeah exactly i'm
paying a penance because i made fun of
nicki for having a black toilet did you
get it for talking [ __ ] i don't know man
why don't they make black toilets they
do they do people don't use it my
grandma in mexico she calls dark green
toilets
toilets with cushions uh cushions
remember that back in the 90s people had
cushions that's the fuzzy the carpet
ones too why don't we have that why
don't we all have that it's so comfy i
remember my mind we should put more
fabric in our bathrooms yeah i remember
my aunt saying let's keep your butt warm
like no it's like crust that's gross why
did we not think about this i moved when
i was moving to koreatown this is not
not a joke
i had only grown up in households with
carpet
as
in the bathroom oh god and when i when i
looked at this place in koreatown i was
like i don't know there's no carpet in
the back oh no oh god
you don't realize that you grew up in
white trash until later
hillbilly
wow dude i've never seen carpet in a
bathroom until
like last maybe september-ish i think
that's what it was like we took a cabin
trip and i saw carpet in the bathroom i
was so repulsed yeah i'm like people
live like this yeah ask nikki it's not a
joke either yeah
she's like that is a [ __ ] she's
like your parents are in the bathtub too
in that same bathroom you have to keep
the kitty litter in the bathtub
his family oh his family oh my goodness
they had kitty litter in the bathtub in
the same bathroom as the carpeted floor
with the padded toilet seat
there was a mobile
house there was a thing i could smell it
double wide mobile home parked out front
wow the padded ones are always like with
the
yeah
cracked
you when you sit down yeah in your
thighs
i thought meth was rock candy [ __ ] yeah
all right guys
well thank you so much for watching uh
make sure to follow steve on his podcast
hey check out my podcast it's called
[ __ ] they don't tell you it's a show
where me and nikki try to tell you about
all the things that we wish that we had
known about also i do a show called
crypticorner that you can check out on
me and nikki's patreon you uh it's on
patreon.com
sticky
and uh yeah i tell people all my crypto
moves i sold my car for crypto i'm
already up thousands on that move but
maybe by the time you watch this i'm
down
so we will see if you like gambling
check out steven if you want to get on
the rise yeah the ride of your life
[ __ ] go yeah yeah
corner um and also make sure to rate us
five stars on itunes and give this video
a thumbs up visit our sponsors visit our
sponsors that's how you can show us your
support for the show we'd really
appreciate it and also comment down
below what are some things that you
didn't know about the opposite sex until
you started living with them because
it's a pretty interesting interesting
topic all right guys i was folding one
of nicky's shirts one time i'm not
kidding and my hands were bigger than
the shirt
it was like it was like folding an elf
shirt yeah and i was like what the [ __ ]
and i pointed us out there i was like
look at how [ __ ] small your shirts
are it's crazy how's this even going
your body you got big old hands though
alright guys see you later bye